previously on TV since I would name you
the hand of the king
[Applause]
reading is there a rule that fluorescent
lighting is not allowed to function
correctly and anything related to the
horror genre show is immediately testing
my patience by starting with a
jump-scare I know you want to dip a
little bit of the Kings horror into your
a nostalgia milk but just know you are
already on thin ice seriously there's no
stairs option in this highly [ __ ]
dangerous laboratory area the stomach
organ is clearly trained in cinematic
tension because it weights a full 20
seconds before attacking it's completely
helpless prey Mustafa is a sprinkler
going in November the night of November
6 1983 was below freezing in Indiana so
I'm pretty sure the wheelers are just
resource wasting [ __ ] I love these
kids together if there was an Emmy for
Best ensemble group of children that
give off 80s vibes and somehow aren't
completely annoying they would have it
on lock
yes Knight Rider staple of the 80s and
we want to make sure that you know this
is the 80s but considering mrs. wheeler
just said it was a school night and that
they could finish their campaign next
weekend then Mike explained that they've
been playing for 10 hours you'd have to
assume this is a Sunday which is all
well and good but Knight Rider aired on
Fridays in 1983 man we are filling up
our 80s nostalgia bingo card real fast
cuz we have a full-on outbreak of kids
on bikes going on the show 1980 so hard
it reminds me of the time I survived on
a three pound bag of peanut M&Ms for a
week it seemed like a great idea for a
while and then it became increasingly
clear I should have thrown in some
protein every once in a while stranger
slender man how is this creature
unlocking this from the outside
even if telekinesis is one of its powers
would it really know about slide locks
and how to release them really we're
gonna do the same thought the monster
was one direction but it was actually a
different direction twice in the first
eight minutes of the show will is still
holding a loaded gun but for some reason
decides to lower it and wait for the
attack instead of at least trying to
shoot this kid has been pretty smart up
until now why the sudden case of lamb to
the slaughter
this themed man sometimes a song is so
perfect for a show that you wonder if it
existed first and then they built the
show around it this is one of those
times perfection who the hell are the
duffer brothers sure the Cohens the
Faroes the Wachowski 's have paved the
way for sibling teams to be a thing but
they still also use their first names in
the credits right I guess I'll just have
to make them up then
sorry Abner and Basel duffer this is
your own fault and in this very moment
as if a new David was being chiseled by
Michelangelo the phrase dadbod became an
acceptable thing to say about another
human being if the waking up hungover
with multiple empty beer cans on the
coffee table
smoking shirt was outside and smoking
while putting deodorant on wasn't enough
to convince you this man has a pretty
serious alcohol problem and nicotine
addiction let's have him chase some
pills with a beer just to hit that point
home how did this phone get hung back up
we'll let it fall after his failed 911
call so the demagogue can come back
through and tidy up how considerate step
right up and get your tickets for the
Freak Show
because Cosmo and Derby duffer can't
make sure we know it's the 80s without
school bullies meet stranger things
version of Tweedledum and tweedledumber
ignite brawl face useless that's racist
and Buddhist and dentist now it's
ridiculous
you know if I had to pick an early
favorite character for this series it's
got to be barb she's such a good friend
to Nancy and just takes no one she's her
own person and the depth of writers have
given her will pay off for years to come
good thing she's not going anywhere
Steve left this note early this morning
but when would he know that Nancy found
it is he stalking the girls bathroom
from his arrival all the way until first
period I mean yeah probably but man
teenage hormones are [ __ ] up a
make-out session in the bathroom I'm
sorry I lived through the 80s if there's
one place we didn't make out it was the
bathroom teenage girl is braving this
absolute German Palooza foursome
pre-class tongue wrestling also how is
no one else using this restroom at one
of the busiest times of the school day
kind of card game are these two playing
where sergeant random here is so
carelessly showing his hand by facing
backwards and yet hopper can save the
day by moving one card around in a hand
this guy's been staring at for the last
three minutes garden gnomes again well
I'll tell you what I'm gonna get right
on that
joy spires can't find her son
mm-hmm he's holding a doughnut in your
mouth the comp version of biting an
apple because hopper giving a sarcastic
response to a missing child report is
about the ass holiest thing I can think
of right now
also Flo couldn't have led with this are
the garden gnomes really more important
than a missing child I know this is the
80s and all but Jesus Christ also here's
an extra sin just for making me say the
word gnome again after barely surviving
that no movie nonsense and now I'm
realizing I'll probably have to send the
sequel damn it ninety-nine out of a
hundred times kid goes missing the kid
is with a parent or relative I assume
the statistic was bought so I did some
research and Jim's actually right less
than one percent of child abductions are
stranger-danger thinks but you still
made me do the [ __ ] research show so
seeing you my show if they took the
precaution to seal the gloms to their
sleeves with duct tape and why wouldn't
they have taken similar measures with
their boots now probably the other giant
sentient goo slathered portal in this
lab area why in every television show
and or movie is the teacher always
yelling over the bell the homework
assignment at the kids are already out
of the classroom and he should know when
class ends you can't stop a few seconds
before and give out the homework
assignment and this is a very involved
assignment but if someone didn't hear
the 12.3 part sorry man it's not my
fault you left the classroom at the
correct time when I was giving
instructions sorry boys I hate to be the
bearer of bad news but it came don't
these three have another class to get to
I guess hanging out with a grown adult
in his office is a valid excuse for
ditching sorry to interrupt but Michael
Lucas and uh Scott why is this I'm gonna
say principal pointing out and naming
each of these boys both he sweater-vest
mustache and the boys themselves already
know this info wouldn't he just pop in
and say I need these three guys to come
with me you're a bit of Mirkwood
I have no that sounds made-up to me it's
from one of the Rings The Hobbit does it
matter how dare you Lucas this is
exactly the reason Dustin has a job
waiting for him on the sins team
whenever he wants it I thought I wasn't
allowed to see it as long as you don't
have nightmares I don't get scared like
that anymore not even of clowns
spoiler alert also pretty sure it's Mike
that might want to keep clear of clowns
in the future this Joyce just now
looking here based on the flashbacks
this must be a place Will's frequently
act like like this like a Cadillac to
these kids would have walked it on a
bike like this might also be an active
crime scene so maybe don't be moving and
handling
evidence until the folks from the hit
spin-off CSI Hawkins arrived okay well
how nice of Chester to conveniently
start barking at the shed when hopper
came over its almost looking read the
script light bulbs in the stranger
things universe have great dramatic
timing especially considering the
monster should be long gone by now are
they reacting to hopper is he a hopper
Gorgon thanks for coming out - we really
appreciate she died a few years back
sorry
this kid geez lady do you go around
knocking down the gutters on people's
roofs - I mean since you seem so good at
eavesdropping good thing there's always
a town gossip around when we need to get
to some heavy-handed ex positioning and
pronoun gaming few things are more 80s
than the boyfriend at the window trope
and Falcon and Grover duffer continue to
mainline that nostalgia my problem is
that it never takes the time to explore
the deeper aspects of the things that's
referencing meaning we spend all of our
time at the surface level which is
really only the tip of the Spielberg oh
my god they killed Toby they know what
11 is capable of right how did they
think holding her at gunpoint was gonna
go down also with all the 80s references
in this film not giving Matthew Modine a
set of keys dangling from his pocket was
a missed opportunity know which polymers
occur naturally starch and cellulose but
those aren't the only examples of
natural polymers and the question didn't
ask for a specific number how would
anyone pass this cooking test even
idiots do you Carrington you're a
beautiful man sue Miller as great as
this show is it definitely has an
annoying habit of characters calling
each other by their full name like
Will's gonna buy that Dustin you're not
bringing out a mint-condition copy of
too late the heroes and a thunderstorm
get your nerdy head out of your ass
sorry I went dark there
why are you doing this to me
you hear me why are you doing this to me
[Music]
Tama than that we turn on the black
light that the dungeons and the drags
begin to get da furs you guys do the
truffle shuffle the bat is leaving the
cave Roger that give me back my son